hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well
what a gar calls the criterion of
verifiability is arguably the most
central concept in his short work
language truth and logic and he
introduces it of course in Chapter 1
within the very first several pages
after telling us how his project differs
from that of other people he's going to
lay out what this criterion is and make
a few distinctions within it he'll also
use those to distinguish himself against
several other positivists logical
positivists actually and set out L
tamiya a reformulation of this principle
in terms that are going to run
throughout and be applied within the
entire work including chapter 1 so what
is the criterion verifiability he tells
us that it says that a sentence is
factually significant to any given
person if and only if that person knows
how to verify the proposition which it
purports to express now that's a little
bit of a strange formulation and there's
a bit of technical jargon going on there
so we want to unpack this before we move
factually significant it has some sort
of sense it's going to be able to be
said to be true or false to any
particular person right or a group of
people and then the if and only if
that's a biconditional it's very
important it's defining what it means
for a sentence or an expression or
proposition to have that status then
where he's going to talk about how to
verify the proposition we'll get into
that in just a moment and then notice
the proposition which it purports to
express that part you could actually
leave off if you wanted to technically a
sentence expresses a proposition this is
some basic logic stuff there but we
don't actually need to worry that much
about this this particular issue we're
more interested in this issue of what
does it mean to verify and how to verify
so what observations would lead us to
taking a definitive stance on the truth
or falsity of this proposition he says
that if the person knows how to verify
it right if they know what observations
would lead them now notice this
important provision under certain
conditions to accept the proposition as
being true or rejected as being false so
there's a lot of things that we can say
well you know I'm not sure whether this
is true or false and that doesn't mean
that they're therefore unverifiable or
they're not factually significant as
we're going to see we just have to know
how we could actually go about verifying
them if indeed we we can if a sentence
doesn't fit that description
then it's what he calls a tautology and
he discusses that here or it's what he's
gonna later call on the work strictly
speaking nonsense and both tautologies
and nonsense are pseudo propositions
pseudo is actually not the best term to
use the
technically speaking it means lying or
false right but as we're gonna see
tautologies they're always true right
and nonsense is neither true nor false
so it's a little bit of a misnomer there
but he says that if the proposition is
of such a character that the assumption
of its truth or falsehood is consistent
with any assumption whatever concerning
the nature of one's future experience
then it is if not a tautology a mere
pseudo proposition the sentence
expressing it may be emotionally
significant right but it's not factually
significant so there's emotional
significance and we get into that with
the whole emotivist theory of ethics and
you know perhaps in other parts of the
work as well and then there's factual
significance it actually says something
about the world that we can observe and
experience now a set of distinctions
have to be made and these distinctions
are made in part to respond to you might
say knee-jerk responses that that a
person could easily make to say well
there's very little that's actually
verifiable in this this definition so
one of the key distinctions that he
makes first is that between what he
calls practical verifiability versus
verifiability in principle there there
are many things that we can't
practically verify for example in the
time that we're existing right now the
video that you're watching might not
actually be me dr. Sadler talking to you
and it could be a deep fake as we call
them now right and we're gonna have more
and more of these as time goes on unless
legislation to somehow pass to rule
these out we now have the technical
means to take words and feed them into
rather sophisticated ai's that can then
generate those words in the voice of
somebody else and with the face of
somebody else with the right facial
expressions
and it's just gonna get better and
better and better better in the sense of
getting more and more able to deceive us
okay so how would you actually verify
that this video was me talking to you
well you'd have to be here in the room
standing right next to me
verifying for yourself that that was the
case or perhaps there'd be some other
electronic marker that would work as a
proxy that we could use but that's
that's that's practical verification
that's not really what is feasible for
anybody who's watching this now isn't
instead what we have is verifiability in
principle were you to be here
counterfactually you would be able to
observe that it is indeed me and not a
robot not a dr. Sadler impersonator not
the product of a deep fake that is
giving this lecture on a Jair and for
that matter how do we know that a Jair
wrote this book how can we verify that
for the guy's dead he actually lived
quite a long life I know some stories I
believe it or not about a gar that
because he came to Southern Illinois
University where I did my graduate
studies and people said some rather
interesting and colorful things about
him how do I know that these anecdotes
are actually true I could go back and
you know ask the people but is that
verifying no it's not practical
verification but verification in
principle I suppose were I to have been
there I could do that and there's all
sorts of things that we don't know at
the present air uses an example that we
actually can verify now whether there
are mountains on the further side of the
moon he says no rocket has yet been
invented which would enable me to go and
look at the farther side of the moon so
I can't decide it by actual observation
but I do know what observations would
decide it for me yeah as is
theoretically conceivable I were once in
a position to
make them I'll give you another example
from something that's coming from our
real life right now we have two aging
pets both of whom have things you know
going wrong with their organs in
different ways and they can take MRIs
and ultrasounds and interesting things
like that and they can say well you know
there appears to be this thing going on
here but unless we do a biopsy we can't
really be sure of what's happening but
we're not going to do a biopsy because
it would be incredibly invasive so we're
just gonna say that this is the case
that this is the case it is in principle
verifiable if we wanted to do a biopsy
which would be you know intrusive
painful and probably expensive and most
likely unnecessary but we're not going
to do it and so it's only verifiable in
principle and we could go on and on and
on we can have all sorts of interesting
hypotheticals about what a person would
do I would give my life for you
how do you verify that do you actually
have to see the person give their life
for you or can you imagine some
circumstances in which that would be
made true or made false so he gives do
some interesting examples he gives you
an example of a metaphysical pseudo
proposition taken from Bradley the
absolute enters into but is itself
incapable of evolution and progress Ayer
says this is not even in principle
verifiable I have no idea what would
allow you to determine anything about
the absolute and whether it enters into
evolution or progress he says I mean
it's possible that these are code words
and the person is using these English
terms in a rather non-standard way but
in that case it has to be translated
into a more ordinary approach to
language so we could in fact verify it
so that's the distinction between
practical verifiability and
verifiability and principle very
important one to observe another very
important distinction is between what
air is going to call strong and weak
senses of verification
he says a proposition is said to be
verifiable in the strong sense of the
term if and only if it's truth could be
conclusively established and experienced
but now he's telling us about the other
side it is verifiable in the weak sense
if it's possible for experience to
render it probable so he says that why
do we need to make this distinction well
some positivists want to adopt
conclusive verifiability as the
criterion of significance and he says
that's gonna run us into some problems
if we think about general propositions
of law and here he doesn't mean legal
systems he means things like natural law
so for example arsenic is poisonous all
men are mortal a body tends to expand
when it's heated
he says it's of the very nature of these
propositions or truth cannot be
established with certainty by any finite
series of observations why because there
could always be some sort of exception
and you can't actually observe every
possible case of these so you're making
an assumption that you know what we
observe in the future is going to be
similar to what we've observed in the
past and in the present and that nature
has certain regularities to it once
we've observed enough of it so according
to the strong conception of verification
those natural laws or you know whatever
we want to call them generalizations is
probably better than laws any one of
them would not be verifiable and then
we'd have some real problems right we
wouldn't be able to do science instead
air proposes that we can rely on
probability so he says that here we go
he thinks that no proposition other than
a tautology can possibly be anything
more than a probable hypothesis and he
says if this is correct the principle
that a sentence can be factually
significant only if it expresses what is
conclusively verifiable would be self
stall to fiying that is it would be
making one stupid literally it has a
criterion of significance
so you know that's a key thing
he also says we also cannot accept the
suggestion that a sentence should be
allowed to be factually significant if
and only if it expresses something which
is definitely confute about by
experience confute abomey pnes it can be
refuted it can be shown to be wrong it
can be shown to be false so he says
those who adopt this course assume that
although no finite series of
observations is ever sufficient to
establish the truth of hypothesis there
are crucial cases in which a single
observation can definitely confute it he
thinks that that's not the case either
so we have to rely on probabilities so
error is proposing this this entire
criterion in terms of verify ability and
principle and a weaker sense of
verifiability that can be based on
induction so he ends up coming to
another formulation of this he says
let's make our position clear
let us call a proposition which records
an actual or possible observation an
experiential proposition then we can say
that it is the mark of a genuine factual
proposition not that it should be
equivalent to an experiential
proposition or any finite number of
experiential propositions but so here's
the criterion now simply that some
experiential propositions can be deduced
from it in conjunction with certain
other premises without being deducible
from those other premises alone now why
bring in this extra stuff about these
other premises and not from these other
premises alone because generally in
order to get something off the ground we
actually need a whole set of proposition
some of which may not be empirical some
of which are not being brought into
question here but we should be able to
deduce not just induced but deduce he
says some experiential proposition from
whatever it is that we want to take as
being factually significance that that
is as having a meaning as something that
can be said to be true or false and not
in the sense of a tautology which is
always true rather we want to be able to
say what we could verify from this
that's this proposition so this is
another way of formulating it this is
going to be a absolutely central idea
running throughout the entire text and
you could say heirs approach in general
you